As you might imagine, with an important
area such as image loading,
there are actually a large number
of libraries providing this
exact functionality,
each a little bit different.
Comparing similar libraries can
be a laborious process, but
can really give you a deep understanding
of how the libraries work.
For Sunshine, we'll use Glide, the image
loading library that is flexible and
has a number of optimizations to
allow it to work efficiently within
a scrolling list and work alongside
the activity and fragment life cycles.
It is used in a number of Google Apps,
including Google Camera, Photos,
Field Trip, and the Google I/O app.
With an easy Getting Started guide,
good documentation, and
the full source code,
there's a lot to like.
Let's see how we can use Glide for
Sunshine.